[Applause]
[Music]
I'm maiden is the only rock dance with
their own private jet and do you know
who the pilot of that pilot jet might be
well yes that's none other than the lead
singer Bruce Dickinson and listen there
are not many people who deserve more
admiration than mr. Dickinson if it
wasn't enough to be one of the most
successful heavy-metal singers in
history he's also an experienced
commercial pilot a radio host a writer
an entrepreneur and the CEO of one of
the most innovative aviation companies
in the world and you now might be
wondering well why are we talking about
Bruce Dickinson on visual politic I mean
what does iron Mazen have to do with
politics at all well let me tell you and
Maidan singer Bruce Dickinson's Cardiff
aviation signs on to manage national
carrier for Djibouti positive aviation
is a company that provides maintenance
to airline companies we could say that
iron maiden has landed in Djibouti but
in this case they didn't come to perform
they came to sell airplanes train the
pilots and designer system so that
Djibouti can have its own Airlines but
just wait a minute because this is the
really important thing here you might
think that the airlines of a country
like Djibouti aren't a big deal right I
mean we're talking about a really poor
country located in the Horn of Africa
with a population of less than a million
inhabitants
[Music]
however what if I told you that Djibouti
has a big chance of becoming the next
Dubai
what if Bruce Dickinson is actually one
of the first visionaries to decide to
invest in this country think about it
why you look at this map here it is
Djibouti and this is the Suez Canal and
this is the Red Sea any oil tanker who
wants to go from Abu Dhabi to Europe
must pass through here all of those
Chinese mobile phones sold in the UK
travel through this area one under ten
ships that sail the planet are passing
in front of the Djiboutian coasts but
make no mistake this is not a quiet
region in fact the opposite is true
remember the Somali pirates well this is
Somalia and this other thing is called
Eritrea and it's not a chill place
either and this other thing you see on
the map this is called Yemen and it's in
the middle of a civil war it turns out
Djibouti is the only peaceful country in
the entire region
now hold on a minute once again because
there is still more here now if you've
been following this channel for a long
time you should already know that
Ethiopia is one of the fastest growing
countries on the planet they are
becoming a textile superpower and they
have more than 90 million inhabitants
and guess what else
Ethiopia it's got no coast this means
whenever they want to sell their
textiles they have to do so through the
Djibouti port and yes I can probably
guess what you're thinking right now are
we really talking about a new Singapore
or Dubai or is them something missing
here I mean maybe you might be thinking
out should I be like Bruce Dickinson and
invest in Djibouti well today we are
going to answer all of those questions
but before we do as always let's take a
look back at the history
location location location after
everything I just said about treaty some
of you might be thinking right now I
mean why have I never heard of this
country before well the answer to that
it lies in their history which is not
really very different from their
neighbors in the year 1977 after a
peaceful referendum djibouti became the
latest country to gain independence from
their french colonizers and just as it
happens in similar cases Djibouti became
a one-party dictatorship until the 1990s
mr. Hassan Ghul adapted on and other
members of his tribe controlled the fate
of this country torturing members of the
opposition became a common practice and
the ruling party got really really rich
off the profits from the port now you
could say that back then
Djibouti was a textbook example of a
gate keeper state you see in such poor
countries the whole economy is dependent
on just one thing in the case of
Equatorial Guinea for instance that
thing is oil in the case of Djibouti
well that would be it sport since the
dictators have no money to pay a big
army to control the whole country they
must focus all of their oppressive
powers in the area where the money is
located so Djibouti sport was completely
secured while the rest of the country
was in total chaos there were murders on
the streets there was rape there were
all kinds of other horrific crimes now
as you can probably imagine this is not
the ideal situation do you create
companies or attract any sort of foreign
investments now bad in fact that in the
90s a civil war started between the
government and the opposition parties
and tribes and it's full not exactly a
recipe for success
and while this is where the first
difference between Djibouti and the rest
of their neighbor countries comes in the
way the government solved their problem
was surprising to everybody basically
after years of bloody fighting and
thousands of killings on both sides of
the battle
mr. Absalom went to the other party the
so-called front for the restoration of
unity and democracy and essentially said
to them look dude okay
get a grip there is money for everyone
here why can't we share it all and just
stop fighting each other and this this
is how to beautii got its first unity
government a government that combines
most of the local political parties now
there is still political opposition in
Djibouti they but they can really not
even make campaigns and nearly sign that
our presidential elections they are
essentially boycotted this explains why
after demands later his nephew Omar Gil
a win the elections without comes close
to 100 percent of the votes so yes not
exactly a leaving democracy but this is
just the beginning
despite the internal fights by the year
2001 Djibouti was still a very corrupt
country with a very weak global position
I mean think about it we're talking
about a really small country less than 1
million inhabitants placed in the middle
of one of the most violent regions on
the planet
[Music]
next to them I mean Somalia which is
virtually Anarchy where different tribes
are constantly at each other's throats
and then on the other side we have
Eritrea a dictatorship that makes North
Korea look like Sweden and in the south
of course there's Ethiopia the biggest
regional power and one who at any moment
would be happy to invade your booty's so
they can have a coastline
so in summary they were far from being
in a peaceful situation but then when
everything seemed to be against them
history decided to give the country a
marvelous break our enemy is a radical
network of terrorists and every
government that supports them all of a
sudden america with george w bush as
their presidents declared war on
terrorism and this meant sending troops
to all the areas where al-qaeda cells
were presence which includes of course
the Horn of Africa and is there any
better place for building military bases
than Djibouti it has a peerless location
and two governments that corrupt as it
is congratulate itself for being stable
and having no ties with terrorist groups
now do you remember when I told you that
the Red Sea is extremely dangerous for
merchant ships you know all the pirates
and stuff well from the Camp lemon
airbase American troops can chase those
Somali pirates and not only the
Americans can do this I mean in ten
years the list of countries who have
installed military bases in Djibouti
it's pretty much never-ending we can
indeed find French Italian and Spanish
troops there indeed the only place where
Japan has a military base abroad is
Djibouti and as you might be able to
imagine with so many world powers having
a military presence here China well this
is where China comes into the picture
China opens first overseas base in
Djibouti and of course in such a poor
and small country having so many foreign
armies is a fantastic deal I mean think
about it all of these soldiers they need
food to eat they have to shop and they
also need to have some fun this means
lots of jobs and lots of money for the
entire country and on top of all that
it's almost the biggest problem Djibouti
had for investments
[Music]
with so many military bases in the
country only an insane person would dare
to invade them in fact there are a few
places in Africa that are safer than
Djibouti nowadays add to this the
perfect situation for international
trade routes and you can easily
understand why this country has been
growing at a 5% annual rate since the
day American troops but their boots on
the ground us as you might have guessed
know not everything is perfectly
wonderful here
despite this growth Djibouti still has
an unemployment rate higher than 50
percent yep you heard that right
one out of two Djibouti uns has no
stable job in other words these airlines
that Bruce Dickinson helps create are
just sending soldiers and people from
NGOs that travel to places like Somalia
or Ethiopia but just wait a minute here
because the times they're certainly
changing in this country
[Music]
a man and his vision remember this name
Ilyas mosa de la now you might be
thinking well he's the new president
rice well no certainly not
Djibouti has kept the same president for
the past 20 years this man well he's the
minister of economy and finance but in
this case the finance minister is even
more famous than the president we needed
to plan over a longer period we accept
that we will probably not be able to
achieve all of our objectives during the
current administration but vision 2035
clearly sets out the aspirations of the
president and his government yes Musa
Diwali now if you've been following
visual politic for a while this vision
2035 thing will probably remind you of
something remember this video where I
told you about rwanda strode out of
poverty yeah this vision 2035 is a
carbon copy of Rwanda splats in many
aspects the Djibouti government wants
their ports to have state-of-the-art
technology just like those of Singapore
and Dubai but for this while they need
money but not only that Dowell a also
knows that in order to make the economy
work you need to diversify
[Applause]
[Music]
if a country only relies on one single
industry a small crisis could easily be
the country's downfall then again if you
want to diversify your economy you still
need money and you need a business
friendly environments and corruption and
lack of rule of law are seldom friends
of businesses and a foreign investment
and in these areas Djibouti
Martha get a gold medal for example
despite the port being the main economic
driver in this country nobody you can
see the accounting books this means many
government officials are getting rich
without anyone knowing if this was not
enough part of the local legislation is
based on Sharia law nobody can even
protest this fact because Djibouti is
among the 10 countries with the lowest
freedom of speech in the entire world in
just 2016 the government sent three BBC
journalists to jail because they wanted
to talk about election fraud now as you
can imagine this is certainly hurting
the country's opportunities and what's
worse well it's almost impossible to
change the system at the end of the day
the ruling class is already making
enough money from the port and the rents
they get from all of those foreign
armies
[Music]
further they also have enough security
that makes them not afraid of a popular
uprising in other words if Dalloway the
finance minister wanted to change the
political system and as he says in his
vision 2035 paper improved the
governance all over the country he has
an impossible job right well dear viewer
well sometimes miracles they do happen
when he breaks ground a massive Chinese
backed free trade zone in other words if
you gon change the whole political
system in the entire country just change
a little part of it in this special
economic zone everyone can buy property
and build without having to wait months
and months to get government permission
this makes it harder for government
officials who want to take bribes now on
the other hands all of the regulations
are going to follow Chinese law
essentially this is little short of a
tiny little Shenzhen in the middle of a
country the agreement calls for the zone
to handle 7 billion dollars worth of
trade or within 2 years
Djibouti will create a unified custom
system with China establish a trade
center and set up a currency clearing
system
[Music]
so well what can we expect now well the
idea of making special economic zones is
certainly nothing new and it's been
proven to work many times in fact this
is the system that let Dubai become the
metropolis that it is today the idea is
that when you have a special economic
zone both the citizens and the political
elite can see firsthand what happens
when you have transparent laws and a
good framework for companies to follow
if this experiment works politicians
will be more willing to implement real
changes in the rest of the country
all right so in summary we have an
African country where security is
granted by foreign armies and who is
starting to apply serious reforms we
have a country with the perfect location
and size to become a financial and
logistical center in one of the busiest
areas on the planet so it seems that mr.
Dickinson has found a virgin paradise
for investments doesn't it well hold on
just a second because this does not mean
Djibouti is going to become a freedom
and human rights Haven I mean at the end
of the day neither China nor to buy are
really such havens either but this can
be at least the beginning of the end for
poverty in this region
so the question now is well do you think
these positive predictions do you think
they'll become true is this a good time
to invest in Djibouti or is this going
to amount to nothing more than just
hopeful predictions well do leave your
answer in the comment section below and
if you want to know why do bi is so rich
well check out this video here's a
spoiler it has nothing to do with oil
also do not forget to check out our
friends at the reconsider Media podcast
the podcast that provided the voices in
this video that are not mine and don't
forget we publish brand new videos every
Monday and every Thursday so hit that
subscribe button and you won't miss a
single post and if you liked this video
give us a thumbs up and as always see
you next time and if you want to learn
more about politics and here even more
of my lovely voice you can join us at
reconsider media we have a podcast at
reconsider mediacom slash podcast see
you there
[Music]